[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
oh my gosh we just got a brand new first
look new footage at the Wan Division
Series and the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series and they both look
amazing and we got a lot we got Falcon
throwing the shield which looks
absolutely fantastic we see Baron Zemo
and surprisingly we see Wanda and vision
as well
we even see one to change her different
appearances including the first time
that we ever actually see her in her
full Scarlet Witch costume and not to
mention in one scene she is pregnant so
that absolutely confirms that her twin
boys Wiccan and speed are definitely
coming in the one division series and
then not to mention we saw loki we got
our very first loki footage as well all
of this footage looks absolutely amazing
if anybody was worried about what these
disney Plus Marvel Studios shows were
going to be like if they were worried
that they were going to be bad worry no
more these look like movies they look
absolutely incredible Marvel is going to
do an amazing job at them so the three
shows that are going to be coming to
Disney Plus for Marvel Studios phase
four we just got our first look at and
they look absolutely fantastic
we saw a falcon and we saw Bucky we saw
Baron Zemo we saw a vision back to life
and the Scarlet Witch finally in her
full costume and our very first look at
Loki this was an absolutely incredible
TV spots 3 TV show first looks in one
let me know what you think about this
this makes me a hundred percent more
excited than I already was before these
look amazing let me know what you think
in the comments down below I'll do a
full breakdown on everything that we saw
at the Super Bowl tomorrow don't forget
to subscribe notifications turned on
like the video and comment with your
thoughts down below so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 as always thank you all so much
for watching we'll fluff